PAMELA FOX: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
PAMELA FOX: How are you?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PAMELA FOX: OK.
How are you?
AUDIENCE: Good.
PAMELA FOX: All right.
OK.
Good.
I know this is like the time
of the afternoon where
typically you sleep.
And they did just turn
off the lights.
But I will try and be as loud
and obnoxious as possible in
order to keep you awake.
So my name is Pamela fox.
I'm a product engineer
at Coursera.
And today I want to
talk about feature
detection in the real world.
So this shit's gonna get real.
All right.
So you guys are in
a Chrome track.
And presumably you guys are all
on the Chrome track and
doing web development stuff.
And you're probably all pretty
excited about HTML5, right?
Whoo.
AUDIENCE: Whoo.
PAMELA FOX: So HTML5 is awesome,
because it's bringing
us all these things that for
years and years we wanted as
web developers.
And we had to do all
these crazy hacks
in order to do them.
And finally, the browsers are
just making it really
easy for us, right?
I remember once spending two
months implementing rounded
corners on this little gadget
back when I was working at
Google, and finally getting it
to work in IE6, and then
taking it to UX Review with
Marissa finding out that
apparently we didn't do rounded
corners at Google.
So stuff like that, right?
These days it would take me
one line of code to put a
border radius on there and
then get it rejected.
And hey, life would
go on, right?
So HTML5 is great, because we
get all these new features.
But we're getting them
incrementally, right?
So we have them in
some browsers.
We don't have them in
other browsers.
We have kind of parts of the
features in some and they
don't quite work.
So that means we actually have
to worry about whether a
particular feature is actually
supported, because most of us
probably have to actually
develop things
for multiple browsers.
If we could, we'd probably just
tell all of our users,
hey, just use Chrome.
I've tried that.
It kind of works.
So what do we do?
We think to ourself
like, all right, I
want to use this feature.
But first I need to see
if it's supported.
How should I do that?
The obvious thing to do is to
ask the browser, like, hey, I
want to use this feature.
Do you use that?
And we do that via this
technique that we
call feature detection.
And we have various
ways of actually
doing feature detection.
So here are some examples.
If we want to know if a
browser supports some
JavaScript API, we might
ask, OK, does
window.webkitAudioContext
exist?
If it does exist, than this
browser supports that
particular JavaScript API.
If we're trying to see if a
particular HTML element works,
we can try creating the HTML
element and seeing if it gets
particular attributes
automatically applied to it by
the browser.
If we want to know some CSS
works, we can just create an
element and see if that style
property is actually a key on
that element.
And most of us probably use
Modernizr, which is a library
that does these detections for
you behind the scenes.
And then you just
ask Modernizr,
hey, does this work?
So that's feature detection.
And it sounds like it's
actually really great.
All we have to do is say, we
want to use this feature, just
tell the browser, hey,
tell us if it works.
So it's really, really awesome
when it works.
It's a great idea.
However, it doesn't
always work.
Sometimes it's impossible
to detect a feature.
Sometimes you get false
negatives, positive falsities,
whatever you want to call
them, all those things.
And you need a different plan.
And a lot of times what
you do instead is
use user agent detection.
And this is where we just look
at the navigator.userAgent.
And we try to understand
what device and what
browser a user is using.
So a very basic check here.
If I want to know if they're on
an iPad or iPhone, I'm just
looking for iPhone or iPod
in that user agent,
doing a regex here.
This is where we have
a lot of regex's.
I hate regex's, so I will never
make these up myself.
But they get worse.
So if I want to check for mobile
browsers, maybe the top
mobile browsers, here's a check
that gets a bit more of
a crazier regex that's going
to get me maybe the top 10
mobile browsers.
But it's not that simple.
There's a lot more browsers out
there and devices in the
world, especially as you
go international.
I know a lot of you are
from outside America.
And I'm sure you have Android
devices that I've never even
heard of, right?
So if you really wanted to
check for every mobile
browser, you get something
like this.
I think this from
mobilebrowserdetect.com.
And as you can see, there's
a lot of mobile
browsers in the world.
Do you actually need to
check for all of them?
I don't know.
I don't know you're doing.
But this is an example of
how intense user agent
sniffing can be.
And we usually don't want to do
user agent sniffing for a
couple reasons.
First of all, we have
to write regex's.
And I don't know about you,
but I don't like regex.
The thing is, it's very
easy to get it wrong.
It's generally easy to
get regex's wrong.
But it's also really easy to get
user agents wrong, because
user agents, they're kind of
these crazy strings that
browsers come up with.
And browsers are always trying
to fool developers into
thinking that they're not
what they used to be.
So I think the new IE10 has
gotten rid of something in its
user agent string that people
normally sniff for to find out
that it's IE, because IE10, they
don't want you thinking
it's IE anymore, because
it's cool now.
And then--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PAMELA FOX: Oh, you guys
didn't get that memo.
OK.
And then some browsers, like
if you're viewing IE with
Chrome Frame, it'll tell you
Chrome in the user agent.
But then Chrome Frame might
not actually be
running on the page.
So that's kind of confusing.
And then of course every user
agent string in the world has
Mozilla, because that was
the original dupe.
So user agent detection
can be really tricky.
And it also means that when
you're detecting the user
agent, if that user agent
eventually does come to
support a feature, you've
prematurely blocked it.
If you say like, hey, Safari
doesn't support this feature,
we're not going to use this
feature in Safari, and then
Safari tomorrow comes out with
a release that supports that
feature, you've probably moved
on to other things.
The chance that you're actually
going to update that
bit of code that blocks Safari
users is really small.
So we don't like user agent
detection because it's often
not future-thinking.
It can really easily leave us in
a state where parts of our
site aren't working as well when
they actually could be,
because these browsers
do move fast.
But it is a tool that
we can use.
So here's the thing.
We have these two tools, feature
detection and user
agent sniffing.
And a lot of people will tell
you, hey, you've got to use
feature detection.
You've got to use feature
detection.
That's the only way.
And I definitely do try to.
But I've run into all these
cases where it hasn't quite
worked and I've had to use
other techniques instead.
So I wanted to share those with
you so that hopefully
when you guys are working on
using these fancy new features
yourself, you'll know what to
look out for and you'll know
how to react yourself so that
you can spend less time
figuring out how to detect
things and just move on to
actually making stuff happen,
which is what
we all want to do.
So let's talk about
a few cases.
LocalStorage is this cool,
lightweight storage API.
It's actually supported in a
quite a few browsers now.
It's from the W3 Web
Storage spec.
And it's a very simple key
value store that you can
access from JavaScript and use
to store in cache data from
your application.
And I thought it was
really cool.
So I wrote a library on top of
LocalStorage called lscache,
which was inspired by memcache,
which is a tool we
use on the server and would
allow me to store stuff in
LocalStorage with a particular
expiration and then they would
get automatically kicked out.
So in this library, I thought it
would be responsible of me
to actually check to see if
LocalStorage worked in the
browser before I attempted
to store anything in it.
So I needed to figure out how
to do this detection.
So I started off with the most
basic thing I could do, which
is, OK, LocalStorage on
window and not null?
Therefore, this browser supports
the LocalStorage API.
That was my very naive
first attempt.
But what happened is that you
could have LocalStorage
supported by a browser.
It didn't mean you could
actually use it, because it
could be that the browser was
currently in incognito mode
and doesn't let you store
LocalStorage.
It could be that the
LocalStorage was over quota.
It could be just for whatever
reason-- there was one version
of iPad where they just
turned it off.
So the only way you can actually
check to see if
LocalStorage works is to
try and use it the way
you want to use it.
So my LocalStorage check then
turned into this, which is,
OK, let's try to set an item
in the cache and remove the
item from the cache.
And if we're able to do that
and we don't get any
exceptions during that time,
then OK, LocalStorage works.
So the only way I could actually
check this was to use
it exactly the way I wanted
to be able to use it.
So I went to that check.
Now, even that caused
me some problems.
So I was using this in
a mobile web app.
It was a PhoneGap hybrid app.
And I noticed that my web app
was taken a long time to load.
And I was trying to get
this load time down.
So I profiled it.
I put little new Date
in between all the
things that it did.
And I tried to figure out, why
is it taking so much time just
to get to this main screen?
And I found it was actually
taking something like 300
milliseconds on Android in
order to get through this
LocalStorage detection check,
because in my code I had
script source equals
lscache.js.
It would execute that code.
And that code would
immediately do the
LocalStorage detection check.
So what I realized was I needed
to stop doing that
detection check on page load,
and defer it, only do it later
when I actually needed it.
So what I did is I made a little
cached variable to
remember where LocalStorage
works, because we don't want
to do this check all the time.
We just want to do it once.
So basically what happens,
every time you try to use
lscache, it will check to
see, have we figured
out yet that it works?
OK.
If we haven't, let's
do that check.
Let's remember it.
And then next time when they
use it, we'll remember.
So what I learned here is that
you have to be careful when
you're checking if something
supports an API not just that
it supports it, but it supports
the way you want to
use it, I mean, LocalStorage,
you could actually be in a
mode where you could
read it but you
wouldn't be able to write.
But maybe you only care about
reading, in which case you
should just check for that.
So there's a lot of subtleties
to when we say something is
supported or works.
It's, again, a bit more
complex than that.
You also need to make sure that
you don't let feature
detection slow down your site.
It's always simple to do
everything up, do all your
checks upfront.
And then you know you can
always have it there.
But you don't want to sacrifice
the users loading
performance just
for simplicity.
This is the unfortunate thing
pretty much when it comes to
performance, your code can
start off beautiful.
As soon as you start worrying
about performance, your code's
not going to be beautiful
anymore.
You're going to have to
implement caching.
And it's not going to
look very clean.
But sometimes we have to make
our code look not as beautiful
in order for users to have
a better experience.
So we sacrifice a little bit of
developer happiness for a
little bit of user happiness.
And I know that's really
hard for us to give up.
But it's important.
And along with this, every time
I encountered something
with this feature detection, I
thought to myself, OK, what
would I want out of browsers?
What could browsers give to me
as a developer that would have
made it easier for
me in this case?
So here, it would've been
awesome if I could just ask
the browser like,
hey, browser.
Can I use LocalStorage storage
in a read mode?
Can I use LocalStorage
in a write mode?
OK.
Great.
And then the browser could
figure out the most optimal
way of checking and I wouldn't
be up to me.
So the good thing about
browsers, having browsers give
us these checks, is that they
could do it in a very fast way
and a very efficient way, ways
that I couldn't necessarily do
because I'm not going
behind the scenes
in the browser code.
So I hope that this is something
that browsers do
going forward with things
like the storage APIs.
And I think that IndexedDB
actually does
have stuff like this.
So they learn.
All right.
Whoo.
So then we have this thing
called FormData.
FormData is another
addition to HTML5.
And it's something that lets
you take data from all your
form inputs, serialize
it, send it
in an XML HTTP request.
The idea is that you
don't have to
use jQuery.ajax anymore.
And I thought, oh, this
is really cool.
And I saw all the Google Dev
Rellers were tweeting about
how cool FormData.
And I was like, man.
I want to be cool like them.
I want to use FormData.
So I implemented it for a signup
form on this website I
made last year, so that
when you signed
up, you would actually--
it would go through this code
here, which would say, OK.
If window.FormData--
we're just starting with
this basic check.
If window.FormData, create the
new FormData from the form.
Do a new XHR.
Send that FormData to the XHR.
If not, then we just go down
to our Ajax technique.
So I was like, OK.
This is awesome.
I've been all proper.
And I've implemented the feature
detection check.
And I've done a fallback
technique.
And I tested it and it
works and it's great.
And I put it out there.
And I tweeted about it.
And I felt really good.
But then I got all these reports
from Safari users that
they weren't able to sign up.
I was like, well, this
is not very good.
Sign up is somewhat a crucial
part of an application.
So I was like, what is this?
Why can't they sign
up on Safari?
Because it worked fine on my
Safari, and I realized that
there was this particular
version of Safari--
it was like 5.1.50 or whatever,
only on Macs, maybe
on Windows-- but this particular
version of Safari
where FormData didn't
quite work.
It pretended to work.
But it didn't actually work.
And what would actually happen
is that when you created that
FormData object, it would
create it and
pretend it all worked.
But then there was nothing in
it, which is kind of horrible,
because people would be trying
to sign up and there would be
no data going to my server.
So I couldn't even find out what
email address they put in
in order to tell them like, oh,
hey, I fixed it, because I
was getting an empty string.
So that was pretty bad.
And the other bad thing is
that there was no way to
actually do a detection check
for this, because FormData has
no accessors.
You can't ask FormData to tell
you what's in it, to
say get a key out.
Give me the length of
what's in there.
It's just this blob that
you can't look inside.
And maybe there's
nothing in it.
So I was like, OK.
I'm going to have to just
blacklist Safari, because I
knew it had a problem and
that was my only option.
So I ended up coming up with a
detection, user agent sniffing
for Safari.
And I said, OK.
If window.FormData and we're
not in Safari, then lets go
send it on.
And I could have done the very
specific version of Safari,
but I didn't want to-- you know,
if they introduce the
bug in one version, who's to
say they're not going to
introduce it in another
version?
So I just wanted to
move on with life
and get it over with.
So what I learned here is
that it sounds really--
these new APIs, they seem
really exciting.
And if you go to conferences a
lot, like you guys might, you
hear about these new APIs
and you're like,
oh, that's so cool.
I'm going to go home
and implement it
immediately for my app.
And you get really excited.
But you've got to be careful
about using new APIs, because
the bugs in them are new.
They're not documented.
New bugs will come up in recent
versions of browsers.
And especially if you're doing
something, if it's some
mission-critical part of your
site, like signup, I wouldn't
recommend trying out
a new API there.
If it's a mission-critical part
of your site, then just
go with the old techniques.
They might not be as cool, but
we've had them for years.
And people have tested them.
And people know what all
the bugs are with
file upload in IE7.
And they've figured them
out in libraries.
So I would say try and use those
old APIs and libraries
that people have written,
because they're battle-tested.
And you don't want to be using
something so new and shiny for
something that's so important.
Now, for browsers, we really
need accessors for anything
that has storage in it.
Like with LocalStorage, if there
was no accessor, I would
have had no way of knowing that
it actually successfully
stored something.
So this is something that
they should add to any
sort of API like this.
So now let's talk a bit about
CSS, because this is something
that you can run into as well,
because we have a lot
of fancy CSS now.
We've got shiny animations
and transforms.
So I was working on that mobile
web app, using PhoneGap.
And I had this embedded
WebView.
And I decided to do it as a
mobile web app because I
already knew HTML and CSS.
And I was like, I already
know HTML and CSS.
I'm just going to use
it to make this app.
I'll be great.
I don't have to learn
something new.
And at the time, I
was doing it for
both iPhone and Android.
And only iPhone had a set
of design guidelines.
Android hadn't really come
up with anything yet.
So I just followed the iPhone
design guidelines.
And they were a lot of like
rounded corners and gradients
and they kind of looked
really bubbly.
And luckily, CSS3 made it really
easy to make something
look iPhone-y, because we have
the box shadow and the
gradient and the border radius
and all of that.
So I had my app.
And it was all good.
And I was feeling good, having
it out on the markets there.
But then what happened is I was
using Android at the time
and I would notice from time to
time that the entire screen
would just go completely
white.
And I would be unable--
there would just be nothing
there anymore.
And I would have to restart the
app or somehow go back.
And it was kind of useless.
You can't use an app that's
just a white screen.
It's highly unfunctional.
So I was like, OK.
Clearly something is not working
in this app that I
need to work out.
And I kind of had a suspicion
that maybe Android didn't like
all this fancy CSS.
I'd kind of heard rumors that
Android wasn't so good with
new CSS3 stuff.
So I suspected that it was
having trouble actually
rendering this.
So what I did was I spent an
entire afternoon sitting there
commenting out CSS, redeploying
my APK to my
phone, scrolling and scrolling
and scrolling, waiting to see
if I got a white screen.
That was probably one
of the most boring
afternoons of my life.
And so eventually, I did figure
out that if I commented
out enough of the fancy CSS,
that I wouldn't get white
screens anymore.
And I didn't want to have to
sit there and figure out
exactly how much CSS Android
can handle, because it was
just really boring.
So I decided, well,
you know what?
I'm just going to get
rid of all of it.
I'll take away the border
radius, the
gradients, the box shadows.
And so it ended up looking
really flat.
Then, conveniently, Android
came out with their design
guidelines, which were the
opposite of iPhone's.
And their design guidelines
were flat,
not gradient, square.
Wow, that's perfect.
It's like you knew
that you were
incapable of handling CSS3.
So that worked out really
well, actually.
But the thing is that I still
wanted to have the iPhone look
and feel for iPhone users and
the Android look and feel for
the Android users.
And I was doing this from the
same code base, so I needed to
detect Android.
So you can see here the
transformation from the iPhone
to the Android.
So to detect Android, it's a
little more complex than you
would imagine.
I was doing the standard user
agent check for popular
Android devices.
I was also using the PhoneGap
API that they provide for
checking device.
And I was also checking the URL
parameter, because I test
my mobile web app in the browser
as well, so I wanted
to be able to just fake Android
when I was testing in
the browser.
But finally, when I decided to
Android, I add the Android
class to the body tag.
And then in my CSS, I can
just say, oh, OK.
If we're looking at a modal
class inside the Android body
class, then just reset all
these fancy things.
Box shadow, none.
No border radius.
Get rid of all that.
Reset it all to zero.
And that worked.
So what I learned here is that
just because something is
supported, does not mean
it's supported well.
It's really easy to throw in
support for these things.
It's much harder to make them
work really well and be really
performant, especially
for this CSS3 stuff.
So you really need to check for
that, and especially if
you're using these
features in bulk.
Part of my problem was that
I had kind of an infinite
scrolling interface.
So there was potentially lots
and lots of these features
that were kind of building up
and being used by the browser.
I think if I only had a limited
amount of usage of it,
I probably could have more
easily controlled it and
predicted how it would form.
But since I had more and more of
this CSS3 features building
up, I think that contributed
to Android kind of freaking
out and going, oh,
it's too many.
I'm just guessing that's
what Android does.
So if you have any sort of
interfaces which potentially
get bigger and bigger amounts
of content and don't have a
finite cap, really be careful
about your performance there.
I worked on the Google
Wave team years ago.
And we had that problem
with Waves, Waves
that got way too long.
They just had too much
DOM inside them.
So we really had to look at
that DOM and say, OK, we
probably shouldn't be using
a table to make all of our
buttons, because that really,
really adds up when you get
these really long Waves.
So definitely any place where
you've got this scrolling or
lots of things adding
up, look out for it.
Now for browsers, I just want
browsers to know their limits.
I would much rather that
Android realize that it
couldn't render my fancy CSS and
just not done it, instead
of pretending it could do it
and then rendering a white
screen, because white screens
are really not easy to use.
It's like worse than
blue screens.
At least blue screens you know
it's a blue screen of death.
You're like, oh, OK.
It died.
I'm just going to restart it.
White screens it's like,
eh, I don't know
what's going on here.
It's kind of abstract.
So browsers should just
know their limits.
So should all of us.
OK.
So finally I want to talk about
a signup process that we
have at Coursera that I helped
on a few months ago.
So we introduced this thing
called Signature Track, which
is a way of taking courses while
verifying your identity.
And there are a few technical
components of Signature Track.
And we wanted to make sure that
people knew about these
technical requirements before
they signed up, because I
didn't want users to get
halfway through this
multi-step signup process and
then realize that there was no
way they would've able to
complete it and then they get
all mad, like, Coursera, why
you tease me like that?
So the requirements were that
you needed to have a physical
keyboard, because we do this
keystroke biometrics algorithm
and it doesn't work so well
on soft keyboards.
So we wanted you to have a
real physical keyboard.
You needed to have a webcam,
because we took a picture of
your face every time you took a
quiz and when you signed up
and match it to your ID.
So we couldn't have you do it
if you didn't have a webcam.
And you needed to have
a modern browser.
And also you needed to have
Flash, because we're using
Flash to get the webcam stuff.
I know that you can it
in HTML5, but it
didn't work so well.
So I needed to figure out how to
do checks for all of these.
The first thing was a
physical keyboard.
And that was a little tricky,
because there's no such thing
as asking the browser
if there's a
physical keyboard attached.
So we said, all right, well,
maybe we should just look to
see if it's a touch device.
So we started off with this
check here, like is
ontouchstart in window or
DocumentTouch, then OK, we're
on a touch device.
And we rolled that out, but we
immediately got cases where it
thought you were on a touch
device and you weren't and
vice versa.
And people would actually
have physical keyboards.
And we're like, all right.
We are just going to blacklist
mobile browsers.
So basically, you're only going
to be able to do this on
your desktop browser.
And we'll give you a link to
let us know that if you
actually do have a physical
keyboard, we'll
give you that option.
So we ended up doing that,
because we needed something--
I just needed something that
worked to get this out fast.
But the thing is, we
would tell people.
So every time I would detect
something about a user, I
would let them know like, hey,
this is the reason that we're
not letting you do it, so that
then they could see.
And then they could contact us
and say, oh, hey, you say that
you blocked me because I didn't
have a hard keyboard,
but actually I do.
And then we can decide to
unblock them or we can change
our blocking process.
We actually haven't gotten
emails about that check yet,
so I guess it's kind
of working.
Now I just want to give an aside
on touch events, because
touch events are really, really
interesting things.
And there's been a lot of very
interesting articles lately
about touch events and
whether you should be
detecting them and how.
So if we want to look for touch
events, there's a couple
things we have to do across
different browsers to find out
if that browser is capable
of doing touch events.
But there's a difference between
a browser supporting
touch events and the user
actually using touch events.
So if you're on an Android
tablet, you could still
connect a mouse to
your tablet.
And you can actually potentially
be using a website
and switching between using a
mouse and using your finger on
the same web page.
So that means as a developer
you shouldn't be relying on
just the fact that something's a
touch device as meaning that
you should be just be doing
everything reacting to touch,
because a lot of times the users
can connect these other
devices as well.
And I think this is going to
become more and more common,
that we'll have these devices
that are both.
I mean, we all just got that
Chrome Pixel, right?
And a Chrome Pixel is a
touchscreen and a keyboard and
you have a little mouse
down there.
So this is becoming more and
more the reality, so we have
to be really careful that when
we're looking for touch, that
we consider the fact that
they could still
be using click events.
So the standard way--
or one way that you could
actually not care about this
is that you could listen to a
touch event and if you get a
touch event, you would just
trigger your listener for the
click event.
And basically, they would both
do the same thing, so that way
the user can go between using
touching and using click and
your web page should respond
exactly the same way.
So if you are doing anything
right now or thinking about
doing something where you're
detecting touch events and
doing something different, think
to yourself, how would
this work if the user also
had a mouse attached?
How would it work if they
switched between the mouse and
this touch screen halfway
through the interaction?
That's kind of the trickiest,
but it could happen.
And there are some really
interesting articles about
that there.
OK.
So that's an aside.
We also need to detect
the Flash plug-in.
And I just used the SWFObject
library for this, which is a
nice, well-supported library.
And it'll even tell you the
Flash Player versions, in case
you want to support
particular verses.
And I also wanted to
check for a webcam.
Unfortunately, there is no way
to check for a webcam unless
you actually put up the webcam
prompt and ask the user to
give permission.
And I wanted to check for this
before they even got to the
webcam part of the process.
So I gave up.
And we put up a little modal
that said, hey, remember, you
need a webcam.
And presumably if they saw that
and decided to keep going
even though they didn't have a
webcam, well, that's their
prerogative.
So sometimes you just
can't detect things.
And you have to accept that.
So in this case, I learned that
you can't detect things
all the time.
And you have to do
different things.
And if you do decide to block
users, which can be a bad
thing, but if you do block
them, tell them why you
blocked them.
Give them an option to contact
you and explain what their
particular setup is.
And maybe you'll realize then
that the code you're using
could actually be
much improved.
And for browsers, I would really
like for browsers to
give us a way to detect those
physical devices and plug-ins
so I wouldn't have to go through
all this effort to try
and figure it out.
So something like, is there
a physical keyboard?
Are they using it right now?
Do they have a webcam?
Do they have Flash?
Those would all have made my
life much, much easier.
So to finish up, this
is a reminder of
why this all matters.
This is a visualization of
browser support for a
particular feature.
And there's lots more
visualizations of this, but
the point is that, yeah, we're
going to have unequal
distribution of feature support
for a long time going
forward, basically forever.
People will keep coming
up with new things.
Browsers will keep not
implementing them at the same
rate, keep implementing them
in different ways, with
different performance concerns,
with different
attributes supported.
And we're going to just have
to keep dealing with that.
So this is something that we're
going to have to think
about for years to come.
Now browsers are
aware of this.
And browsers are
trying to help.
So browsers, they did
introduce this CSS
conditionals, level 3 spec,
which actually has this
@support rule for CSS, where
you can say, oh, hey.
Does this browser actually
support this CSS?
And then you could serve
different styles.
And they've got the same
thing in JavaScript,
window.supportsCSS.
And this is actually supported
by three browsers now.
So the cool thing is that
browsers are actually
realizing that, yeah,
this is something
developers care about.
And they're trying to come up
with more ways for us to
figure it out.
But this is still really
cutting-edge.
And most of you, we won't be
able to use this quite yet.
So in the meantime, what should
be your strategy?
First of all, don't assume it's
going to be easy, because
sometimes it's not.
And if you assume it's easy,
you might look for an easy
solution and overlook all
the complexities.
Don't just copy the first answer
off Stack Overflow,
which is something I do a lot.
But I'm trying to
cut back on it.
Do use the tried and
true techniques.
So use popular and well-tested
libraries.
Look at the number of forks,
the number of issues, the
number of contributors.
Look at how recently
the change was.
Browse through the issue tracker
and see what people
say about it.
And if you're not
sure, just ask.
When I was trying to figure
out the Signature Track
process, I just emailed my
buddies on the Chrome
team and said, hey.
Is there anything I'm not
thinking of here?
And we don't all of have buddies
on the Chrome team,
but we do all have Paul Irish's
Twitter account.
So I recommend just tweeting
at him, because he really
likes to answer these things.
And he's got the lowdown.
So don't be afraid to ask.
There's a lot of people out
there that'll answer.
And do try feature
detection first.
So use Modernizr.
And you can see all the
different ways of using it.
Also, if you do need to do user
agent detection, use this
library called ua-parser.
It's maintained by BrowserStack
and contributed
to by Google and Facebook.
So it's got a lot of great,
well-tested regex's in it.
And it's supported in lots
of different languages.
And you can also
mix and match.
You can see if something works
and then maybe blacklist it
for certain browsers that
you know have problems.
Certain browsers and versions,
that's the
best kind of blacklist.
Basically, the conclusion here
is that we don't have that.
Do you guys know what
that is up there?
Yeah.
So that's a sonic screwdriver
from Doctor Who.
And basically, it can
do everything.
We don't have something that
can do everything.
We don't have the perfect
solution in web development.
That's just how it is.
But we do have a lot of
tools in our tool box.
And we can learn how
to use those tools.
And we can combine
them together.
And we can try and use the more
sophisticated ones first.
And we also have each other, so
that we can learn from each
other about how to learn
these tools, so we're
not alone in it.
So when you're figuring this
out, look to each other for
the solutions, document what
you find out, write it up,
open source your code, and then
we'll all learn how to do
all this detection together,
so that we can fully take
advantage of everything the
web has for us today.
Got it?
Done.
[APPLAUSE]
PAMELA FOX: So, questions,
yeah?
Anyone have questions?
Speechless.
Doctor Who episodes, perhaps?
There's a little microphone-y
thing there.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So there seems to be kind
of an underlying
theme to all of this.
And that is, you're doing
all this checking.
It almost feels like you're
trying to implement what you
can when you can, rather than
trying to develop to implement
to cover as many browsers as
possible and then dealing with
exceptions.
Am I just kind of reading into
that the wrong way or--
PAMELA FOX: So you're wondering,
am I trying to use
new things--
am I trying like overly hard
to use new things, versus
using the older things?
AUDIENCE: I wouldn't
say overly hard.
But it seems like not just
you, I see a lot of
developers out there.
I feel like there's this push,
this emphasis to use
everything possibly available,
even if it causes
10 times the work.
PAMELA FOX: Right.
Yeah.
I think that's a good point.
I think that we see the new
stuff and we get really
excited about it.
And it makes us feel good to try
out the new stuff, because
we feel like we're on
the cutting edge.
It's kind of like Not Invented
Here syndrome.
It helps us kind of feel like
inventors if we're using the
new stuff too.
And we're going on this alone.
But it's true.
Nowadays, like at Coursera, most
of time I will just try
and go with the tried and true
techniques now, because now
that I've had this much
experience with trying the new
stuff, I like knowing
that it's there.
But I also know that if I'm
going to try it out, I'm
probably going to be one of the
first people to really try
it out in a big app.
And I'm going to have
to struggle with
figuring that out.
And sometimes I'm up for that
challenge, because it can be
quite interesting.
But sometimes I just
want it to work.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So I hadn't quite formed
the question until now
that you've said that.
In your experience, these things
that are out there, are
they generally stable enough
that it's OK for the better
part of the user base
to try to use them
and deal with them?
Or if you've got to really deal
with the general public,
should you just stick with those
tried and true methods?
PAMELA FOX: It really depends
on what they are.
Some of them have been out there
for longer than others.
I guess I've experienced even
with LocalStorage that
browsers introduce new bugs.
And it's even been around
for a couple of years.
We use HTML5 video
at Coursera.
And we still have a lot
of problems with it.
And it's been out for
a year or so.
So we've started defaulting
users to Flash instead.
AUDIENCE: OK.
That right there says a lot.
PAMELA FOX: So sometimes there
are advantages to stuff.
We're using HTML5 video at
Coursera because we get
playback rate, because we can
do the speed-it-up buttons.
So we're using it there because
we're getting a real
advantage to using it.
So if there is a real advantage
in terms of
performance or productivity--
like border radius, I'm going to
use that and just not care
if it doesn't work in other
browsers, because I get a big
advantage there and not
a big decrease.
So it's a balance.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Regarding your
fancy CSS woes, did
you file any bugs?
PAMELA FOX: So did I file bugs
on the Android white-out?
AUDIENCE: Was it Chrome, or was
it the Android browser?
PAMELA FOX: This was
Android WebKit.
So the thing is, when you're
doing PhoneGap, you have to
use the embedded webview, which
means using the Android
WebKit, also known as like
the worst webkit ever.
So I mean, there were a lot of
issues with that webkit.
I think I filed some
issues on that.
But I don't know if I filed on
the white-out in particular,
because it's something where
you'd have to give
them the test case.
And it's kind of a-- sometimes
it can be really complex to
come up with the test
cases for people.
And I feel bad reporting bugs
without a really nice test
case for it.
So I probably didn't.
AUDIENCE: I gotcha.
Cool.
We'd like to help fix those.
PAMELA FOX: Nice.
OK.
Anything else?
All right.
How many of you use
Modernizr now?
Cool.
Any of you guys do ua-parser?
We got one.
Yeah.
I actually had never even
heard of it before, so--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PAMELA FOX: Why doesn't
Modernizr have an [INAUDIBLE]
Flash?
So there is a whole
issue on it.
So this is what I recommend,
like when you use Modernizr,
you'll find it doesn't have
checks for-- there's lots of
things it doesn't
have checks for.
Many of the things I check for
these days, like playback rate
on the video element, Modernizr
doesn't have that.
But if you look in the issue
tracker, you will often find
discussions about it.
So any time you use a library,
look in the issue tracker.
So I always look in
the issue tracker.
So you've got to look and see
what are the common issues
that people are having, to see,
oh, is that something
that's going to hit me too?
And also look for interesting
discussions,
especially with Modernizr.
And I also look to see just when
people respond to issues,
if they're nice or if they're
mean, because if I'm thinking
about using a library and all
the responses on the issue
tracker are kind of mean,
then I don't use it.
So I definitely check out--
when I'm thinking of using a
library, I check out their
issue tracker and their code
history fairly thoroughly,
because any time you use a
library, it's an investment,
because you will encounter
issues with it.
So they don't have
a Flash support.
But they do have a long
thread about it.
And I followed a few links from
there, but in the end
SWFObject was the best option.
It was the most accurate.
Cool.
All right.
You're free to go.
[APPLAUSE]